What are you up to tonight, Changmin?
Tonight is my "TV night." I always stay in and watch my favorite TV shows on Thursdays.
Oh, I see. What do you usually do on the weekend?
I sometimes go out and play basketball.
When I don't feel like going out, I stay home and watch TV.
How often do you play basketball?
I sometimes play basketball with my friends.
But I like to stay home and relax in front of the television most of the time.
Yeah, I realized that many Koreans like watching TV very much.
Yes, they do. Like my family, they watch TV all the time!
How many hours a day do they watch TV?
Well, basically, if they are at home, the TV is on.
So I guess they watch TV at least six or seven hours a day.
That seems like a lot.